horror icon killer doll friends till the
end Chucky has been going strong since
the late 1980s and he doesn't show any
signs of slowing down his reign of
terror wanna play
UCLA film student Don Mancini wrote the
script that will become Child's Play in
1985. originally conceived as a satire
of the marketing industry the screenplay
was about a doll who became the
manifestation of a repressed little
boy's ID carrying out brutal Vengeance
on anyone the child held Manas for
originally titled batteries not included
it was changed to blood buddy to avoid
conflict with a Steven Spielberg
produced movie of the same name around
this time producer David kirschner was
looking for a new project having always
been fascinated and frightened by dolls
he was interested in making a film about
them kirschner got a start as an
illustrator for Jim Henson before
producing the wonderful animated film An
American Tale in the supplemental
material included on the Child's Play
DVD he explained that he was given a
development deal with Disney under the
assumption that he would continue to
produce family-friendly entertainment
the first project he presented to them
was blood buddy while the movie did not
end up getting made by Disney Kushner
did not give up taking Mancini's General
description in the script for the good
guy doll he designed the figure that we
have come to know as Chucky feeling the
script needed some changes he brought on
Friday night filmmaker Tom Holland and
the late screenwriter John laffier to
take another pass at the material
while talking about 80s horror movies
with daily deed Tom Holland explained
that every director turned down Child's
Play saying it was considered to be such
a stupid cheesy explosey premise that
nobody wanted to do it after signing on
Holland was tasked with making the
audience believe that the doll was truly
evil so he created a character of serial
killer Charles Lee Ray the rewrites also
resulted in bizarre Voodoo mythology
that Don Mancini wasn't thrilled with
but had to accept
according
Holland brought Chris Sarandon with him
from Fright Night to play police officer
Mike Norris future 7th Heaven actress
Catherine Hicks was hired as Andy's mom
Karen and Andy was played by young actor
Alex Vincent in his audition Vincent
continuously pretended to forget a line
because he did not feel comfortable
cursing the actor believes it was his
ability to convince the producers that
he forgot the line that led him to
getting the role Brad doreth probably
best known at the time for his role in
the classic One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest was cast as Charles Lee Ray he
physically portrayed Chucky the darling
rehearsals as well although another
actor was brought in to voice a
character in post-production audiences
that didn't respond well however so
doroth was brought back with the
exception of the Remake he has been
playing Chucky ever since
Mancini was brought back to pen the
script for child's play too but the
first film's co-screen writes her John
laffier signing on to direct both men
agreed it would be best to minimize the
voodoo mythology as much as possible the
sequel also gave Mancini the chance to
bring back certain elements from his
original draft
like the climax taking place in the very
Factory where the doll was assembled
producer David kirschner wanted to push
the special effects envelope even
further in the production notes included
on the DVD special effects artist Kevin
Yeager said in order to make Chucky's
speech more realistic we've shut the
film at 18 frames per second instead of
24 when Chucky is talking this allowed
them to slow things down and sync the
dialogue with the mouth movements more
effectively in the film Andy is taken in
by a foster family since his mother has
been committed to an asylum following
the events of the original he forms a
bond with his older foster sister Kyle
who would return later in the series
Kyle was played by actress Christine
Elise it was her first big film role and
she loved every minute of it later in
life Alex Vincent told her he remembered
her as a person who was nicest to him
released on August 30 1991 Charles
played three hit theaters only nine
months after his predecessor strangely
though the character had been aged up
quite a bit in this third film Andy
Barkley isn't a traumatized little kid
but a teenager in military school Don
Mancini explained their creative
decision jokingly comparing it to a
common Trope of rapidly aging characters
and soap operas the intention was to
avoid becoming repetitive by having
every movie be about Chucky going after
the same little boy or developing Andy
Moore as a character according to that
same interview Mancini also liked the
idea of setting the film in a rigidly
structured setting like a military
academy because it gave turkey more
authority figures to go after similar to
his original conceit for the series the
film garnered some controversy in the UK
when it was based as he cited as the
inspiration for a horrendous murder it
wasn't very well received critically
either according to Rotten Tomatoes it
is still the most poorly reviewed
installment of the series it would be
another seven years before we got
another movie starring Chucky and after
the next film the series would never be
the same following the success of Scream
the horror genre was reinvigorated not
only did several copycat movies try to
cash in on the film's high concept but
there was a concentrated effort to be
self-referential meta and more stylized
it was in this new atmosphere that
1998's Bride of Chucky was able to take
the child's play franchise in a bold New
Direction David Kirchner credits the
cover art for a video of the Bride of
Frankenstein as inspiring him to discuss
the possibility of creating a love
interest for Chucky with dom Mancini
like the classic Universal horror sequel
there would be more humor this time
around as well regarding the more
comedic tone of the film Don Mancini
said he structured it like a romantic
comedy by making it about
misunderstandings between characters who
keep getting themselves into pickles to
kick the visual style way up director
Ronnie Yu was brought in at the time he
had been known for his film The Bride
with white hair and he connected with
the visual descriptions and the script
feeling it was very similar to his
directing Style having a second doll
also resented new technical challenges
it required an even bigger team of
puppeteers and Tiffany's slender design
left very little room for the motors and
wires required to operate her it was
worth it however as Tiffany has proven
to be an indelible character for the
franchise going forward
take it from me honey plastic is no
substitute for a nice hunk of wood
the Mancini wrote the parts of Tiffany
for Jennifer Tilly even though he didn't
know her at the time according to
Jennifer Tilly's diary which was
included in the special features for the
pride of Chucky DVD she wasn't overly
thrilled with the idea at first after
calling her manager to find out why she
hadn't had a job recently she found out
that there was an offer coming through
for a horror movie about a killer doll
she knew it was Chucky right away and
thought that would be the end of her
career
in her manager ended up asking for a
dollar amount so they didn't think the
producers would go for she liked the
idea of working with director Ronnie Yu
but knew that a friend of hers wanted
the part and didn't think the production
would agree to her salary quote to her
surprise they did agree and Jennifer
Tilly entered the Chucky universe
I hope he left real for dessert you know
it Pookie her writings indicate that the
work she did on sale was difficult
because of the uncomfortable clothing
they put her in an awkward dancing and
the killer migraine but she mostly
enjoyed the experience most of her work
was done in the recording studio with
Brad Dourif and she seems to have had a
blast of working with him after running
into dwarf on a plane the two agreed
that working on a Chucky movie was a
pretty sweet gig
despite the success of Bride of Chucky
it wasn't until November 2004 that Seed
of Chucky was released
and sini started writing it immediately
following the release of bride but the
horrific massacre at Columbine High
School made the studio nervous since the
film featured murderer's parents trying
to bring their child into the family
business that's producer Corey siennager
pointed out in the making of featurettes
conceiving the Seed of Chucky bride and
Bracy inherent silliness of the concepts
and pushed the humor and horror together
that same sensibility is supercharged in
seed that's a filmmaker's blatantly
mugged themselves by making the movie
about Jennifer Tilly starring in a
Chucky movie as Tiffany with the actual
Tiffany trying to transfer her soul into
the actress's body
Jennifer Tilly
I want to be a star
the iconic John Waters was brought into
the film because of his love for the
Chucky character Mancini found out about
that love when Justin Whalen who played
Andy in Child's Play 3 worked on Waters
film Serial Mom and discovered that he
had a Chucky doll in his bathroom rap
artist red man plays himself in the film
as well Mancini liked his performance
but mentioned that he initially imagined
Quentin Tarantino in that slot Seed of
Chucky is a special installment in the
series as it sees Mancini stepping up as
writer and director for the first time
it also made Chucky a father of a
gender-fluid child with dual
personalities named Glenn and Glenda
that kind of representation that would
continue later in the franchise
Jennifer Tilly's diary was also included
with the special features of Seed of
Chucky she was excited to return but
money negotiations got in the way when
she heard that they might replace her
with an actress from Baywatch she signed
on she detailed some of the Strife
Mancini experience trying to get the
movie made not only did the school
shooting give the studio cold feet but
Mancini's script made them nervous as
well they thought the script was too
funny too gay and there was too much
Tilly she of course took offense to that
last one apparently the studio wanted a
scary movie and not so fast so the film
was shelved she attended the premiere of
Freddy vs Jason with Mancini to support
their friend Ronnie Yu and because
Mancini felt that if the film was a
success it would get Seed of Chucky
greenlit seed indeed got the green light
the next day to these experience on the
film was significantly harder playing a
version of herself was much more
demanding the technical aspect of the
puppet work was far more rigorous and
the shooting process was generally
grueling both and Mancini joked about
not returning for a sequel at one point
because they were so exhausted by the
production however until he raped on the
film everyone on set cheered and
applauded her performance so much that
she cried with gratitude
it was another nine years before we saw
another Chucky movie during that time
Dom Mancini and David Kushner explored
the possibility of rebooting the series
and remaking the first film however
confusion about the rights of that 1988
film and the waning interest in horror
remakes made them decide to reset the
tone of the series rather than the
entire franchise 2013's Curse of Chucky
is a darker more atmospheric and even
scarier movie than its immediate
predecessors part of that tone is
communicated by the set itself Mancini
said the majority of the film on an old
Victorian style house that he needed to
be what he described as a reflection of
the character's lives the movie was
filmed in Winnipeg and while the spooky
interior of the house was created in a
studio the exterior was actually a bed
and breakfast that Mancini found online
after Googling Manitoba Victorian
architecture not only does the film type
back to the legacy of the previous
entries by bringing back Jennifer Tilly
and Alex Vincent in the finale but Brad
Doris daughter Fiona dorif was cast as a
kind wheelchair-bound character named
Mancini auditioned a lot of actresses
for the part but none of them nailed the
role like Fiona proving it wasn't
nepotism even though her dad was very
happy that she joined the cast
only four years passed before Cult of
Chucky was released the 2017 sequel
picked up where curse ended Andy has
captured a Chucky doll that he can make
suffer for all the trauma the evil Toy
has put him through Nika meanwhile is
locked away in an asylum this setting
was appealing to Mancini because he felt
that if an inmate at this kind of
facility were to suddenly claim that a
doll was talking to them no one would
believe it the movie also takes a lead
that Mancini has been trying to do for a
while which is a concept of multiple
versions of Chucky now I can be me and
me and me
by possessing multiple good guy dolls
Charles Lee Ray is able to cover more
ground and weak more Havoc than
previously seen this presented several
technical challenges of course luckily
the film was extensively storyboarded
meaning the puppeteers and the rest of
the crew had a detailed blueprint of how
to make everything work in one of the
biggest Cliffhanger endings in the
series thus far Chucky passes his soul
into Nika's body for the first time in
decades Charles Lee Ray is a human body
again and this time he was played by
Fiona dorif
the rights to the original Child's Play
were owned by two Studios MGM and
Universal an Australian businessman
named Christopher scales attempted to
purchase MGM in 1989. but was not
interested in horror movies so the
studio gave Kirsten a rise to the
sequels and shared the rights to the
original film Krishna went on with the
help of Steven Spielberg to get Charles
play too and the other Kirks that
produced sequel sets up at Universal MGM
set up the rights to do whatever it
wanted with the concepts and characters
featured in the original Child's Play
and the idea of a remake arose they
approached Mancini and Kirchner to see
if they were interested but they both
turned it down they were still actively
working on developing the Chucky series
and it didn't like the idea of the
market suddenly becoming confused if
anything Mancini was straight of
offended the movie cast Mark Hamill as a
voice of Chucky and changed the law
almost entirely with no connection to
the other films whatsoever outside of
character names
Mancini and Kirchner expanded Chucky's
world even further in the TV series
Chucky which premiered in 2021 on USA
Network and sci-fi instead of just
picking things up from the ending of
Curse of Chucky the focus moved to
Charles Lee Ray's hometown of Hackensack
New Jersey this show made a conscious
effort to move into the realm of young
adult fiction by having Chucky
manipulate a teenage gay character named
Jake wheeler their relationship mirrors
Mancini's blood body concept with Chucky
intentionally going after the people who
make Jake's life difficult the lgbtq
plus representation is also front and
center Jake's relationship with his
classmate Devin is a kind of honest
depiction of a young gay romance that
Mancini said he has always wanted to see
the first season explores Charles's
origin with Fiona doroth playing a young
Charles Lee Ray and meeting the
character of Tiffany For the First Time
Fiona also returns as sneaker still
possessed by a Chucky personality Andy
Barkley was also back alongside his
foster sister Kyle with the two of them
hunting down as many Chucky Dells as
possible
after the events of season 1 Jake goes
to live with a new family and has a new
Foster brother named Gary unfortunately
this new life doesn't last long Chucky
tracks down Jake and kills his foster
brother with an explosive this leads to
Jake Devin and the enemy turned friend
Lexi being blamed for his death they're
sent to a Catholic Rehabilitation Clinic
called the school of the Incarnate Lord
The Twist is that the school is in the
same building that used to be the
boarding school where Charles Lee Ray
grew up by setting much of season 2's
story in the same building where Charles
grew up Chucky sets out to bring the
child's play franchise full circle by
further exploring Charles's upbringing
and helping audiences learn more about
the events that led to him becoming the
Lakeshore Strangler the season delves
into his relationship with his childhood
psychiatrist Dr Mixter who nurtures as
murderous ways rather than trying to
subdue them when I first met you when
you were seven
there was a strain of innocence in you
despite her more interesting qualities
this relationship between psychopath and
psychiatrist is a staple of many stories
surrounding fictional serial killers Dr
mixter's nurturing of Charles's violent
behaviors mirrors that of many other
psychiatrists and killer relationships
in television such as Evelyn vogel's
relationship with Dexter in Dexter
the third episode of season two hail
Mary introduces a concept never before
seen in the child's play franchise is it
possible for there to be a good Chucky
after all Chucky is part of a line of
dolls called Good Guys in Hail Mary Jake
and his friends test this Theory out
they capture a Chucky that's scouting
them but he refuses to reveal anything
about the other Chucky's plans so they
tie him down pry his eyes open in a very
clear homage to A Clockwork Orange and
use aversion therapy to try to make
Chucky docile and more receptive to
their suggestions shockingly the plan
actually works or at least it seems to
the doll begins going by the name good
Chucky and helps defend the teams from
the more evil Chuckies interestingly
this is not the first time that Creator
Don Mancini had the idea to introduce a
good Chucky Mancini revealed that he'd
originally come up with the idea for
Seed of Chucky but the concepts never
made it into the film however he felt
like the show's second season was a
perfect time to bring good Chucky to
life since the Catholic setting allowed
for a thematic focus on Redemption
Chucky might still have it out for the
show's leading Trio of teenagers but his
Feud with Tiffany is arguably the
homicidal's primary focus especially as
the second season comes to a close
Chucky and his ex-wife have a
complicated past and ever since her
introduction in Bride of Chucky Tiffany
is shaken up the dynamic between Chucky
and his victims the few between the two
opens a door for some wacky Antics
including scenes where Tiffany is
mistaken for actress Jennifer Tilly who
also exists in the world of Chucky she
attends a surprise party thrown for her
that also includes her sister Meg Tilly
the real-life Jennifer Tilly revealed
that it was the first time she'd worked
with her sister since high school you
remember that time in high school When
We snuck out to meet with the Dean
Brothers
what were their names
the twin children of Chucky and Tiffany
Glenn and Glenda also play an important
role in the show originally in seat of
Chucky Glenn and Glenda's personalities
inhabited one doll The Glenn personality
was benevolent while glender murderers
the film ends up spitting the
personalities between two human children
a choice that has long been
controversial however in Chucky Mancini
aims to create a story that Embraces
queer representation and eventually has
the twins return to the Glenn slash
Glenda doll as one merged being now
going by the name of Gigi Mancini told
Gizmodo it was really important to us
that we honor the Tran's experience
through our own cockeyed metaphorical
lens
foreign